now I want to show you just a couple
videos here this is DeSantis talking
about how much he's accomplished at
governor and sort of how he's gone about
doing it
also just made it very clear when you're
going and
position you have to want you're the one
that kind of makes decisions and you got
to make good decisions you know you can
set the agenda and it's all very
important but you just doing that isn't
enough you got to have people in the
administration who share the vision and
who are going to put kind of the agenda
ahead of their own agenda and we just
made it very clear at the beginning
because you can make the decisions if
they're going to act to frustrate your
agenda or they're not carrying out the
agenda then none of this ends up working
out so we said very clearly to people
you know if you're leaking if you're
have bringing a different agenda into
this Administration pack your bags right
now you're gone we're not putting up
with it and the result is is that we've
had over four years we don't leak to the
media there's no Palace Intrigue very
little there's no drama about anything
like behind the scenes all it is is just
daily execution of the mission and
that's the reason why we've been able to
get so much stuff done we don't get
inverted with all the nonsense that's
out there so we set that down on day one
interestingly what's happening with the
the Trump DeSantis situation is that
Trump has really shifted you know a
couple weeks ago he was constantly
calling DeSantis a globalist in a rhino
and he just knows it's not true it's
just meaningless like if if DeSantis is
a globalist and a rhino then is anyone
done like if you're watching this Don is
anyone besides you not a globalist or
Rhino if every right everyone that you
argue with is a globalist or rhino in a
buffoon and a okay fine so it's
just meaningless stuff uh this is a guy
that he endorsed twice that he lives in
his State and all that but he's shifted
from saying all of that kind of stuff
and basically saying he's cheating on
his wife and like all the over-the-top
stuff now he's just trying to get him
not to run and I think that that's an
interesting shift there he's realizing
that the over-the-top attacks are not
working so notice the tone change uh
here this is from yesterday
Rhonda Sanchez is a young man who is not
doing well against me in the polls to
put it mildly I believe that if he
decides to run for president which will
only hurt and somewhat divide the
Republican party which we don't need he
will lose the cherished and massive Mega
vote and never be able to successfully
run for office again I believe that
if he remains Governor which is what
Florida voters assumed he would do
it would be a whole different story just
saying you really need to understand
guys and this is just the truth and and
look I know a huge percentage of my
audience is on the Trump 2024 train and
again there's a good chance I'll end up
voting for him and you know all my
disclaimers related to all this but you
really need to acknowledge a truth here
which is that this is the first time we
are seeing Trump absolutely quaking in
his boots afraid of another candidate he
did the attacks on Rubio and he crushed
him in three days he did the attacks on
Cruz and it crushed him in three days
now both of those guys ended up being
huge Trump backers once Trump was
President so a lot of this is just
racehorse politics and everyone should
make sure their feelings aren't too hurt
but Trump has never had a situation like
this where he did all of his you know
garbage attacks on somebody and the
over-the-top name calling and all the
other stuff and got pushed back to the
point where now he's just he's basically
begging him not to run
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]